uh but most people are gonna get what
they deserve you know most people are
not being defrauded i mean they're just
delusional i mean they're believing uh
you know a pipe dream i mean it's the
easiest thing i mean get rich quick
schemes have been around for a long time
i mean the crypto community didn't
invent that fiat currency is a pyramid
scheme so it's those with access to the
newly printed money first get rich
at the expense of those who get it
latest and last
so
if you just look at the operating
mechanics of fiat currency
it's a really bad deal
for everyone unless you have access to
that new liquidity first
welcome to episode 124 of the michaela
peterson podcast in this opposing view
style episode i talked about bitcoin and
gold and economics with peter schiff and
robert breedlove
bitcoin you have people obsessed with it
with all their life savings in it like
one of my guests and you have people who
think the entire thing is a scam either
way it's a hot topic you go online right
now and put your life savings into
bitcoin or ethereum the platform used
for purchasing nfts or a coin that's
literally a meme your life could change
overnight provided elon musk tweets the
right thing
my first guest peter schiff isn't the
biggest fan of kryptos to say the least
schiff is an american economist
stockbroker and author famous for
predicting economic shifts or events
like the mortgage meltdown he's a
regular guest on national news and host
of the peter shift show podcast
for the second half i had robert
breedlove on robert breedlove is a
crypto enthusiast strongly believes in
crypto's bitcoin being his favorite he's
also an entrepreneur philosopher and the
host of the what is money show where he
has deep discussions with prominent
thinkers from around the world
if you enjoyed this episode please
consider subscribing and let me know
what you think about bitcoin versus gold
in the comments below
schiff welcome to my podcast
well thanks for michaela for inviting me
on your podcast
this is going to be good before we get
started can you give a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
for anyone not familiar with your work
well for a living i'm mainly an asset
manager so i have a company euro-pacific
asset management
that is my main business so i have
clients that entrust their portfolios
with me
and i manage the money what's i guess
unique about the way i'm or my approach
versus let's say
the standard asset manager is i'm i have
a very specific
world view that
really runs counter to the mainstream
narrative
for years i have been pointing out some
serious structural problems that
underlie the us economy
misunderstand understanding led me to
forecast the 2008 financial crisis i did
that very vocally on cable news in a
book that i wrote
crash proof how to profit from the
coming economic collapse it led me to
position uh myself and and some clients
short the subprime market uh prior to
the collapse in 2008 i understood
a lot of the problems
that the fed was creating with its
monetary policy
that not only
really facilitated the mistakes that
were being made on the fiscal side
but created even bigger mistakes
structurally for the u.s economy
and i have been forecasting that
ultimately
we would
go through a currency crisis which i
think we are really on the cusp of now
because we're finally starting to see
the manifestations of the inflation that
the fed has unleashed over the last
decade really starting to show up in a
very big way
uh initially of course the mainstream
that doesn't understand what's happening
is dismissing it uh but um you know just
the way they dismiss the problems
leading up to the financial crisis uh
they're dismissing the even greater
problems now uh so i incorporate this
view into my strategy for
managing money i also i have a or i used
to have a gold company shift gold which
i now work with
uh as you know just i help promote it
and i have a lot of involvement in the
type of products that are sold there and
their approach to selling
because i really uh sold off the company
when i moved to puerto rico a few years
ago
and so i just operate my my businesses
now from here but i also have my own
podcast which actually had its roots
in
my radio show i did a
daily radio show
after my unsuccessful uh senate campaign
back in 2010
i started to do the radio show
ultimately didn't have enough time to
commit to that you know two hour show
five days a week
eventually turned it into the peter
shift show podcast
so i've cultivated an audience there i
talk a lot about economics finance
politics
uh put a you know free market
libertarian austrian economics spin on
everything and
generally you know i i i
i think what i'm doing on my podcast
is giving people
a more accurate view of what's going on
than what they're getting from
conventional media sources which again
still don't really appreciate
the the underlying problems what the
cause is or what they ultimately portend
okay so
what is going on are we in a state of
inflation like rapid inflation is that's
is that what we're seeing and people
just aren't aware
well the fed has been inflating for you
know decades but particularly ever since
alan greenspan showed up uh you know he
really wrote the playbook that his
predecessors have been following
but you know we just got to move from
bubble to bubble
and we're afraid of allowing market
forces to
restructure the economy
in the way that it needs to be
restructured because you know the
process would involve some pain because
asset prices would fall
loans would default investors would lose
money workers would lose jobs but a lot
of this would be temporary because the
workers who would lose jobs they would
lose the wrong jobs so they can get the
right jobs because right now
government monetary policy
is keeping resources misallocated which
includes labor and so you're seeing that
now because there's a shortage of pretty
much everything and that's because we're
not focusing our resources including
labor
on producing the things that we actually
consume because of the fed
uh so much of the investment is going
into you know things that we don't
really need just a bunch of nonsense a
lot of the companies that are getting
financing are not actually producing
goods and services that we need now
they're you know just kind of hair brain
schemes about what might happen in the
future but since money is so cheap a lot
of these mal investments are being made
and that would include everything that's
going on with cryptocurrencies you know
we've got you know over 12 000
cryptocurrencies there's new
cryptocurrencies being created every day
there's a lot of real resources energy
manpower being used to basically conjure
these things into existence
but in the meantime all of those
resources and energy could have been
used making actual things you know we
you know but we're not doing that we're
not you know planting new farm acreage
we're not you know opening up new minds
and producing the resources that the
world actually needs we're just creating
these cryptocurrencies that nobody needs
but a lot of people want them because
they think if they just buy them they're
going to get rich and they'll be able to
buy all the products that nobody's
making and so meanwhile the stuff that
we're not making is scarcer and scarcer
and we have more and more money to buy
it and so the prices are just going to
be going ballistic and you know people
are again we're seeing just a cusp of
that right now
and the the initial reaction is as well
just to dismiss it
it's transitory it's temporary but
oftentimes when you're on the cusp of a
major change
very few people are going to recognize
that that's actually what's happening so
they're going to try to rationalize it
away you know for years and years the
federal reserve was telling us the
problem was there wasn't enough
inflation that their policy goal was
actually to create inflation because we
you know we were suffering from a lack
of inflation which was all nonsense you
know the whole time it was a way that
they justified their excessively loose
monetary policy which they were pursuing
to keep asset bubbles inflated and so
the u.s government could keep spending
money it didn't have without having to
raise taxes so the fed was able to
supply the money by monetizing the debt
but now those chickens are coming home
to roost you know again in a way that
very few people really understand
okay
so
how much of the inflation that's
occurring now is because of crypto or is
it because of other things
well i mean the cryptocurrency market is
one of the manifestations of that
inflation it's one of the bubbles that
has been inflated
by the fed
um now certainly in some communities
like where i live in puerto rico i would
say that a lot of the crypto money
is helping to fuel real estate prices
here as a lot of crypto people are kind
of moving here uh but
you know what one person
is able to spend
is simply what somebody else can't
because
all the bitcoins or all the
cryptocurrencies are just a transfer
right because
the only way you can buy something with
your crypto is if you sell your crypto
but that can only happen if somebody
else buys it so somebody who's buying a
house in my neighborhood and selling
their cryptocurrency it's because some
other fool bought cryptocurrency and
gave them that purchasing power but now
that other person who bought
cryptocurrency
can't buy something else although what
is happening now
is because of all this cheap money
that's sloshing around there are people
who are actually holding their
cryptocurrency
and spending them too because they're
able to borrow money
against that cryptocurrency so to the
extent that the crypto community could
create money through debt which is a
byproduct of what the fed is doing then
it is acting to help fuel the inflation
because now two people are spending the
same crypto because you know it's just
their people are borrowing against it
um
but
more more than it's creating inflation i
think the way the crypto industry
is
magnifying the inflation problem because
inflation is about creating too much
money and so when you print more money
and you have a certain you know given
supply of goods and services you have
more money chasing those goods and
services i think the way the
cryptocurrency industry is making that
worse
is by diverting
a lot of our scarce resources
away from a productive use
to the creation of cryptocurrencies
and and so in that respect we're
creating all this money to buy products
but then instead of creating the
products we're creating
cryptocurrencies
and so we have too many cryptocurrencies
but we don't have enough stuff real
things that people need and people want
again nobody wants bitcoin or any other
cryptocurrency they simply want what
they think they can buy in the future
when they sell their cryptocurrency but
the problem is if we're not making those
things if everybody is just making
cryptocurrencies instead of actual
things well then there's nothing to buy
so all you have with cryptocurrency is a
delusion you have a bunch of you know
wealth on paper but you can't actually
convert it to real things because if
enough people tried to get out there
there'd be nothing there because the
price would implode
what do you think about the places that
are using types of cryptocurrency to buy
products like i know when i was in dubai
you could use cryptocurrency to buy
products on amazon if it was implemented
that way do you think it's feasible
no because there's only a few people
that actually do that i mean the real
use case for
any cryptocurrency is as a token for
gambling right people buy a
cryptocurrency
because they think the price is going to
go up i mean that's really what's
driving the whole thing
and you know because they're buying it
because they think the price is going to
go up they don't even they don't want to
spend it they don't want to use it uh
because otherwise they wouldn't have
bought it you know unless
the only thing you have is
cryptocurrency most people
you know they have cryptocurrency and
then they have
other they have fiat currency they have
a job they get paid in
wages in whatever currency they're
earning
they use that to buy things and if
there's something left over they may buy
more crypto
because they think the price is going to
keep going up but yeah you could always
have a few people that potentially could
could use it as a medium of exchange
but if enough people tried to do that i
i don't think it would work because then
you know then the price would collapse
and the volatility would also make it
impossible
to really use it as a unit of account or
or as a medium of exchange uh so it just
would work but yes if enough people are
just holding onto it and never selling
it a few people can can can transact in
it
okay what about i guess the one use i
saw for it for traveling was because
i've been helping my dad run his company
and we're doing wire transfers all the
time and transferring large amounts of
money takes time and there are fees
associated with it and when i've been
traveling
using crypto you can just transfer
internationally and there aren't fees so
there's fees associated with it but not
fees like transferring
uh money you know obviously that way if
well yeah the cost of a wire you know
bank wire can be you know fifty dollars
in time
yeah well a lot of the banks now require
that you
you know actually show up in the bank i
mean what the reason that a lot of these
bank transfers take time and i know that
because i'm also in banking
is because of the government regulations
that slow it down and increase the cost
so the actual technological
costs of doing a bank wire for a payment
should be very very cheap and it should
be very quick
what slows it down and increases the
cost
is
government regulation
and to the extent that it's cheaper
to transfer crypto is because the crypto
is not subject to those regulations but
that is all going to change i mean a lot
more regulation is coming
and it is going to get a lot more
expensive and a lot slower to transfer
crypto once government starts applying
all of the kyc and aml requirements to
those transactions i mean that was kind
of
the
advantage it had is that it didn't have
all the regulation
but then of course the you know
the regulation comes it's you know you
just have a a moment of time where
you're kind of under the radar
but that's why in some respects you know
a bitcoin is a victim of its own success
because when it was you know under the
radar and you know there wasn't a lot of
attention by the regulators but now all
of a sudden it's all over the place so
the regulations are going to be there
that is going to
uh increase the cost dramatically of of
working with it but the real problem
though with bitcoin
is not
the
speed or the cost of you know you giving
me your bitcoin or you know me giving my
bitcoin to somebody else it's what
happens to that bitcoin
you know while i own it you know or you
know before i transfer it it's the risk
that at any minute
the market value of that bitcoin can
implode
so
that's what really increases the cost is
the risk to the owner
of what happens to their bitcoin you
know because it's like that the game you
know musical chairs i mean what if the
music stops and you know you still have
bitcoin and then that just price
implodes i mean nobody worries about it
when the price is going up and
everybody's excited because they think
it's going to keep going up forever and
you know people got laser beams on their
eyes because you know it's going to go
to 100 000 any day and then it's going
to go to a million
but what happens when the bottom drops
out
and you know bitcoin is dropping
you know
you know
rather consistently
you know it's it's it's too risky to
have any real
you know value stored there because it
could evaporate
and and so
ultimately that's going to be the reason
that it's not going to work as
a a method of transferring money is
going to be cost of the tremendous
amount of risk to the parties that are
involved of how much value bitcoin can
lose
while you're waiting to transfer it or
once you receive it before you get a
chance to get rid of it uh you know
there can be a big drop in value and
that loss you know dwarfs the cost of
transferring you know fiat currency
around
okay that seems fair what do you think
about the use of bitcoin or other
cryptocurrencies for countries with an
unstable dollar
well you mean like el salvador i mean el
salvador doesn't even issue its own
currency which isn't you know
necessarily a problem it could be a
benefit i mean now they use the us
dollar um
and i think the dollar is preferable
than trying to use bitcoin i mean the
dollar's got a lot of flaws i mean i'm
not a big fan of the dollar either but
it works a lot better than bitcoin
as a mean of exchange or as a unit of
account
um you know as a store of value i mean i
think as a long-term store of value the
dollar doesn't work either neither does
bitcoin but over a short window of time
an hour
a week a month you know i think it's
more reliable than bitcoin uh and so
it's certainly easier to use but look
what what countries should do if they
want a sound monetary system we have one
it's gold i mean gold has functioned as
a monetary uh medium for thousands of
years and it does a very good job of
money and once you adopt the gold
standard that doesn't mean that
everybody has to lug around gold bars
you can have money substitutes which are
paper currencies that are backed by gold
you can even have a digital currency
that is backed by the same goal that
have all the efficiencies you know of
cryptocurrencies without any of the
problems without the volatility and with
the reliability of knowing that you have
something that's going to maintain its
value over time uh so that's what
countries should be looking at they
shouldn't be sidetracked into this you
know crypto craze but obviously i think
they get pushed there because there are
a lot of people
in
uh bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
that have a vested interest in trying to
get others to adopt it because that's
the nature of this game that they're
playing right it's a it's a pyramid
scheme ponzi
you need more people right to come in to
bid up the price of bitcoin i mean if
you want to get out right if you're one
of these bitcoin billionaires but you
actually want
to do things with your billions you want
to acquire
other things you just don't want to have
your billions all in bitcoin or ether or
whatever your currency is you want to
buy real estate uh you know you want to
buy you know you're a private plane and
a yacht and you know you want to you
want to do all the things that the rich
people do
right you need a market for your bitcoin
you need somebody to buy that's why
they're really interested in getting
institutions because you know there's
not that many individuals really that
can write the big checks where you can
get the volume so they're trying to get
uh institutions or countries
to believe in this nonsense so that
they'll buy bitcoin so that they can
sell theirs right that's what you have
to do but now the people who are buying
off these whales
they're gonna have to find even bigger
fools with even deeper pockets willing
to buy their bitcoin because that that
that's how this thing works you always
have to find another buyer to come in
because as i said earlier nobody wants
bitcoin right because you can't do
anything with bitcoin you can't you know
eat your bitcoin you know you can't plug
you know plug your computer into it and
power it you can't you know pour it into
your car and drive it it's it's not a
commodity that has any actual use
and it's not a good or service i mean
people say well nobody wants gold i hear
all that all the time from the
bitcoiners sure they do people want gold
for all sorts of things i mean it's the
most valuable metal
in the world i mean it's used in all
sorts of industries apart from jewelry
which is obvious and it's it's not an
accident that we make jewelry out of
gold jewelry is made out of gold because
it's better when it's made out of gold
you know it works better it lasts longer
um but you know it's a great conductor
of electricity and there are a lot of
things that gold can be used for you
know in medicine and you know not just
dentistry but actual medicine i mean
people ingest gold i mean it does stuff
and they use it in aerospace and all
sorts of things and even if you don't
use the gold yourself
somebody else will use it in the future
that is the beauty of gold because if i
don't need the gold today i can hold on
to it and somebody else can use it in
the future because while i'm holding it
it doesn't lose any of its properties in
fact i can hold it for 100 years my
children my grandchildren can hold on to
it and in a thousand years somebody can
use that gold and it's just as good as
if they had dug it out of the ground you
know that day it doesn't doesn't decay
it doesn't rot nothing happens to gold
over time um so you know
gold can function this money but bitcoin
since nobody actually needs bitcoin
everybody who owns it just has to sell
it because there's no
there's no back end user like gold
there's no jeweler who needs gold right
there there's no
computer chip manufacturer who needs to
buy gold
so you always need another speculator to
buy your bitcoin or any other
cryptocurrency so it's a constant
promotional campaign
you know uh where once you in you're
once you're in it you now have to
convert other people you got to bring
more people in and that's where you get
all this pie in the sky evangelism you
know all these promises of you know all
you have to do is buy bitcoin and you're
going to be rich
you're going to be rich beyond your
wildest dreams you're not going to have
to work you're not going to have to get
a job that's old-fashioned trying to
build a business and get rich slowly
just buy a cryptocurrency and you'll get
rich quickly all you have to do is never
sell right that's what they tell you
just buy it and never sell and you'll be
rich
okay so this digital currency backed by
gold
that's actually that doesn't sound like
a bad idea at all tied to something i
mean the government wouldn't like that
because it would be a big competition to
the crap they put out you know their
their fiat currencies but
you're not going to get rich quick
buying a digital currency backed by gold
yeah i mean gold doesn't make you rich
gold keeps you rich if you're already
rich you can stay rich by owning gold
right you don't get rich gold is just is
preserves its value now i personally
think gold is underpriced right now
relative to a lot of other commodities
so i think there is an opportunity there
but it's not like it's going up tenfold
in real terms right you can't make that
kind of promise gold could go up 10
times but only in an inflationary world
where everything else maybe is going up
five times so if the price of everything
else goes up five times and the price of
gold goes up ten times well then in real
terms gold has doubled but you know the
pie in the sky promises a bitcoin it's
going to a million
right or it's going to even a bigger
number than that that's not going to
happen at gold so you're not going to
get that huge speculative development
now where i think there is a big
speculative opportunity and i'm
positioned myself i have a lot of my own
money there and i you know encourage
clients who want to speculate it's in
the gold and silver mining companies
because i think the real value of gold
is going to go up you know maybe double
their triple in real terms and in
nominal terms you know much more than
that but that's because everything else
is going to go up but i think that is
going to mean these gold mining stocks
are going to make a lot more money
than
the analysts currently believe and so
that's what's factored into their share
price
and but since i think everybody is wrong
as to how profitable these companies are
going to be in the future the price
right now is too low so i think there is
an opportunity and i think the people
who are
gambling in cryptocurrencies who think
they're going to get rich there actually
is an opportunity i think to you know
have you know an investment home run
if you get into the gold and silver
mining stocks i think
you know part of the the the the uh
problem now
is
that since so many people incorrectly
perceive that bitcoin is you know the
new gold gold 2.0 they're missing out on
that opportunity
and i think a lot of people when they're
valuing these mining stocks if they
think that in the future people are
going to prefer bitcoin to gold that's
one of the reasons that these stocks are
so cheap in the present because people
have this false
vision of the future where gold is you
know
doesn't have the the the uh monetary
value
that it had in the past
but that's not true i mean gold's future
is just as bright if not brighter than
its past it's bitcoin that doesn't have
a future
okay that's a pretty solid argument
so you
suggest that people do you suggest
people just avoid bitcoin
altogether well you know
look i do
but you know i again you know like you
know jamie dimon was you know made news
the other day because you know jp morgan
i guess is you know letting their
clients
uh trade bitcoin and he said look i
think it's worthless
which is true but some of my clients
don't know that and so they want to
trade it and so i'm gonna let them
basically they're big boys and girls you
know they're adults if they want to do
something dumb you know who am i to say
that they can't now you know you might
want to say hey come on jamie you you
know you got some kind of fiduciary
responsibility you know if you're
smarter than your clients and you know
they're you know doing something foolish
maybe you should you know try to stop
them right i mean you you like it's like
the bartender saying look you know my
customer uh you know he wants alcohol
who am i to say that he's had too much
to drink well you know maybe your
judgment is better especially if the guy
is drunk you don't have to keep giving
them more alcohol when you're the one
that's sober you know and you got some
people drunk on crypto profits and you
know you got you know the bartender
realizes you know what's going on but
part of his argument i guess or the way
jamie dimon looks at it is look you know
if they don't drink at my bar they're
going to the bar next door so i might as
well be the one that makes the money or
maybe even a better analogy would be a
casino right he sees his clients at jp
morgan
gambling instead of investing because
that's where the action is they want to
gamble and he's like well if i don't let
him gamble here they're going to take
their chips across the street and gamble
in another casino
and so why not you know they're going to
do it anyway and so you know why not let
them do it
and and so
you know in my mind look
people should be free to make their own
mistakes
and you know and and i i'm fine with a
lot of young people ultimately look
young people
who are into crypto
you know
i think that
they're going to learn a very valuable
life lesson from the money they lose
and
that's the time to learn lessons losing
money when you're young because you have
a lifetime to make it back and you have
a lifetime to learn from those mistakes
it's the people that are you know older
that are putting their retirement and
ira money and stuff like that this is a
problem
and
i don't like the way a lot of people in
the mainstream media in the investment
community have now jumped on this
bandwagon and are really encouraging
people to gamble
in these cryptocurrencies by kind of
validating them and i think a lot of
that has to do with the advertising
money i mean i'm very critical let's say
of a network like cnbc that has totally
legitimized
bitcoin but i think
it's because they're beholden to their
advertisers because i think their number
one advertiser is
crypto related companies i mean you
can't watch cnbc every single commercial
break i'd say half the commercials if
not more are for cryptocurrency related
investments and so that's what's driving
all the content on the network they're
playing to their advertisers and so
they're really sacrificing their
audience
in order to placate the advertisers
because the advertisers want to
advertise there because they know that
it's like a giant infomercial where you
have all of the on-air personalities
hyping up bitcoin all day long and the
only guests that they invite on really
are pro-bitcoin
and every once in a while they'll bring
on somebody who's kind of bearish but
then everybody will argue with that
person but when the bull comes on who's
bullets about bitcoin they're all like
yeah they all agree and the most
ridiculous thing about it is a lot of
the people who are pumping bitcoin will
say the same type of things that i say
about the federal reserve and fiat money
and inflation
except when i said them on cnbc
everybody laughed at me and said well
that's ridiculous
but when the bitcoin people say it oh
yeah it makes perfect sense right
somehow the arguments are valid as long
as they lead you to bitcoin but if you
say the same thing but then you don't
punctuate the comments by and by bitcoin
right then you know they disagree with
you and if i said you have to buy gold
they would say oh peter you're just
saying buy gold because you have a gold
business i've never heard once
any of these crypto people who come on
cnbc i've never heard one of these guys
say well aren't you just bullish because
you know you're in a crypto business and
your business depends on people buying
crypto and so aren't you just talking
your book they're never accused of doing
that but i never went on their air
without being accused of talking my book
right so it's a complete double standard
so i i do think that at the end of the
day
you know
there's going to be a lot of lawsuits
from a lot of people who lose a lot of
money
and we'll see how that all shakes out
um
but again you know it's a free market
people people need to do what they want
i mean i don't i don't think fraud
should be
legal you know i don't i'm not an
anarchist i believe in you know certain
criminal activity and i think to the
extent that some people are being
fraudulently induced into buying into
crypto
uh and you know they can prove that they
were defrauded and maybe they'll be able
to recover some of their losses
uh you know through the court system
uh but most people are to get what they
deserve you know most people are not
being defrauded i mean they're just
delusional i mean they're believing uh
you know a pipe dream i mean it's the
easiest thing i mean get rich quick
schemes have been around for a long time
i mean the crypto community didn't
invent that and you know it's you know
unfortunately with the way the economy
is right now with all the government all
the regulations you know it's a lot
harder to achieve wealth
legitimately and honestly now than it
was 50 or 100 years ago when we had a
lot more economic freedom and it was a
lot easier to start a business because
you didn't have to deal with all the
government red tape and all the the
regulations and so now so many people
are basically left with the only hope
you know basically a lottery like i'm
gonna buy bitcoin like i'm buying a
lottery ticket and just hope that i get
rich
by winning the lottery
except they think that they're gonna win
for sure right i mean most people buying
lottery tickets realize that it's a long
shot that they're probably gonna lose
but they buy the ticket anyway you know
just in case
uh but all the people who are actually
buying bitcoin they're 100
certain that they've got the winning
ticket uh and so that's what's gonna
make it particularly difficult uh when
reality sets in and everybody wakes up
to
uh you know to that reality uh that all
these dreams were
just dreams and they're not coming true
okay so two questions um one
do you have any guess about what the
time frame for bitcoin is before people
start realizing that that might not have
been a good idea
and then clearly i have no idea about
that i mean look i mean i've been
talking about bitcoin being you know uh
you know fool's gold and tulip mania and
you know ponzi pyramid you know since it
was first brought to my attention when
it was under ten dollars so i mean
clearly i don't know how big the bubble
is gonna get i mean i'd have to say that
at this stage i mean you know when i
first learned about it i mean hardly
anybody knew about it i mean they didn't
talk about it on television
uh i mean i only knew about it because
of the libertarian circles that i
thought i was in you know
so i knew about it early on
uh but now everybody knows about it
and and you know so i i have to believe
that there's not much left
on the upside i mean could it double
again yeah sure it could
uh but that's not that's nothing
compared to what it's already done
and that's not what people expect people
are not buying bitcoin because they
think it's going to double
because a lot of other assets can double
there are a lot of assets that are going
to do a lot more than double so if all
you think you're going to get out of
bitcoin is double there's no reason to
take the risk
because bitcoin can go down 80 90 99
uh much quicker than a lot of other
assets can
so the risk reward wouldn't be there and
i don't think people are buying it
because they think it's going to double
because they think it's going to 10x or
20x or 50x
and that's why they're there and i think
the odds of that happening are
astronomically low
um
you know again i don't even know if
bitcoin can double i mean everybody
seems to think it's a sure thing it's
gonna hit a hundred thousand you know
when everybody thinks something's gonna
happen it usually doesn't
um so it probably won't even get there i
mean let's see if it makes a new high i
mean it could do that right the high was
like 65 000. we're not too far away
we're what fifty five thousand fifty six
thousand so maybe it'll make a new high
uh maybe not
uh but you know i don't know but i have
a feeling that when gold and silver
finally start to move up that could be
the pin that pricks the the bitcoin and
crypto bubble i think the fact that gold
and silver
haven't really made a big move
is creating or helping to feed the
argument that it's because bitcoin has
replaced gold and that's why gold's not
going up but i don't think that has
anything to do with it i think the
reason that gold is not moving up
is because the big money
does not believe inflation is the threat
that it is i think everybody is waiting
for the fed to fight inflation to get
tighter monetary policy and everybody
assumes that that tight monetary policy
or at least less loose than what we got
now at tightening is going to be bad for
gold because they think that gold is the
inverse to you know interest rates that
if if rates are moving up or monetary
policy is tightening that the price of
gold should be falling and so traders
are factoring in
that future decline that they expect
into the current price
and that's what's you know stealing
gold's thunder it's ignorance of
inflation and what's going to happen
it's not it's not that people are buying
bitcoin instead of gold i think that
there are some people who are buying
bitcoin
but they're buying bitcoin instead of
other speculative assets you know maybe
you know maybe they're buying bitcoin
instead of you know a you know a stock
you know a penny stock or you know
whatever they would have gambled in um
but
i think that once
gold really starts to shine
as people start to
realize that inflation is is
not only not transitory
but then it's going to get much worse
and that the fed is not going to be able
to do anything about it
and so
then people are really going to need a
hedge against inflation
and they're going to buy gold they're
going to buy silver
that's what they've always done
those commodities make sense as an
inflation hedge because they're
commodities themselves that have real
uses you can't hedge inflation by buying
something that is not itself a commodity
because what makes gold an inflation
hedge is that gold is a metal and so you
can hedge the price of other metals
copper nickel you know zinc
with gold gold is a commodity so you can
hedge the price of coffee the price of
cotton price of lumber there are other
commodities and these commodities
historically have relationships
based on their use cases
you know
you know one against the other but
bitcoin has no use case it's not used
for anything and so there's no way to
know
you know how much bitcoin
there should be for you know a bushel of
wheat or a barrel of oil or or or a
pound of copper i mean it's nothing
because you can't do anything with it
there's no way to to value it uh so it
can't be an inflation hedge so when
people really want an inflation hedge
and gold starts to respond
uh i think that could be a big problem
for the bitcoin narrative and you know
once it really starts to fall it's a
whole new dynamic
because right now
the the narrative is
buy and hotel because you're going to
get rich because it's always going to go
up
and the fact that people don't want to
sell
is what can keep the price going up but
what happens when new money stops coming
in
and the old money wants out
well the old money can't get out if the
new money doesn't come in
and so that's why the whole thing can
implode right it just it's just on
itself you know it's just it's just you
know just to hold the bottom drops out
and you get a complete crash because
only a few people wanted to get out if
there's nobody who wants in just a small
volume can sink the whole thing
okay one of the values i think i think
this is my last question but one of the
values i think people find in something
like bitcoin is that it's decentralized
so
yeah again that's part of the pipe dream
about you know yeah we want to get away
from the governments we want to get away
from the banks and uh the financial
institutions and i share that i mean it
would be great to get away from that
but as i said earlier you know the
government doesn't want you to get away
from it that's where all these new
regulations are going to come in
um you know that's i mean you look at
like a company like uber right which you
know is a real business with a real
service but one of the values that uber
had
was it got around all of the government
rules and regulations that made taxi
cabs so expensive
right so uber comes in and arbitrages
that by saying hey we're going to get
around all the government rules and
regulations same thing happens with like
an airbnb hey we're going to get around
all the government taxes and other
regulations on hotels and we're going to
pass on that savings to the consumer and
so that's kind of what bitcoin was
trying to do we're going to pass on the
savings of escaping all this government
scrutiny all this government regulation
well you can't do that for long because
the government is not going to allow
that to happen they're not just going to
let that you can see that happening as
all these governments are trying to
crack down on like the ubers trying to
make them a blo you know comply with all
these labor laws and and taxes and all
this stuff that is going to reduce their
appeal because now they're going to have
to deal with these higher costs and
they're going to have to pass those
higher costs on to their customers and
now you know hey uber's not as good a
deal anymore it's it's it's not saving
me all this money like like it was
before so
i mean there
that's part of the allure of bitcoin
that's part of the sexiness of the story
and that's why it really appeals to
the libertarians the free market people
but it's gone so much beyond that now
because there are a lot of people that
are buying bitcoin
that are you know don't even believe in
limited government you have a lot of
socialists that are buying it they're
just buying it because it's going up i
mean everybody is buying it because they
want to get rich i mean look i've talked
about these guys on cnbc they love the
federal reserve they love the fiat
monetary system they can't get enough of
it yet they love bitcoin too
because it's going up and because the
advertisers are showering them with
money
uh so now it's really it's gone beyond
that i mean yeah you have to try to
philosophically
come up with some kind of reason
right you could listen to a guy like
michael saylor you know talk about
bitcoin and if you're just you know
listening he's on and on and on he's all
the time uh touting it because you know
he's got so much invested in it
but you know
it sounds intelligent if you don't
actually pay attention because he uses a
lot of big words and as long as you
don't stop to you know
actually
dissect the meaning
and to realize that it's complete
nonsense that he is that he is spouting
that nothing actually makes sense when
you actually dissect what he's saying
it's just a it's a load of crap right
but it's just designed to just you know
get people to buy bitcoin and never sell
it
and uh you know so that's what's
happening now with it um
but again you know
once once uh the dream turns into a
nightmare i mean this happened with you
know the dot-coms it happened with real
estate you know you can come up with all
kinds you know i talked about beanie
babies a lot i mean people thought they
were going to get rich on b babies and
of course you know once you get into a
bubble and you have that mindset you
know you don't see any reality i mean
you get this you know case of cognitive
dissonance and nobody can reign on your
parade
uh and and that's you know it becomes a
cult it becomes a you know a religion uh
for people
and you know nobody can can tell them
that they're wrong um
and because you know
there's such a
built-in bias once you get involved and
you you you kind of have this whole
dream
about the way your life is gonna be
because you know you you know you found
this you know this fountain of youth
right this monetary fountain of youth
and you know you're gonna have this
fantastic life you don't wanna hear
anything about that hey it's not true
you know just psychologically your whole
brain now is gonna tune out anything
that is going to you know contradict you
know what you've built up uh in your
mind and what you think is gonna happen
and i think to a lot of people what they
think is you know if i if if i
if i give up if i sell i'm just gonna
miss out it's like that's the fomo right
the fear of missing out
and
that is you know even more powerful than
actual fear right people it's like you
know the greed and the mentality
where
if i can't sell because my friends won't
sell and i'm going to be the idiot that
sells and they're all going to get
richer than me
and and so but that emotion is going to
eventually be replaced by the fear of
losing whatever they've got
but i think bitcoin is going to have to
drop precipitously
before that emotion kicks in so people
are already probably going to lose
70 80 percent of their
money before they start getting worried
about losing the rest of course they
should be worried about losing it right
now but that's not going to happen but
once they lose most of it then they'll
then they'll be worried about losing
what they got left
okay
that was very entertaining thank you
peter schiff that makes sense too
that makes sense where can people find
you online if they want to find you
well you know they can go to the peter
schiff show
my podcast is on shift radio
it's also on my youtube channel the
shift report
so if you just want to listen to my
you know content i don't just talk about
bitcoin i mean i can't not talk about it
it's like so i do talk about it but most
of my podcasts are not about bitcoin
they're about bigger things
um
and so i talk about all about that but
again too if you want to
really
build a portfolio
an investment portfolio
that will
do well
in the world the way it's going to look
i think we are on the precipice of a
major change in the global economic
order i think the days of the dollar
being the world's reserve currency are
numbered and that number is obviously
much smaller than it was before
so i think that americans are going to
be in for a rude awakening when the
dollar depreciates relative to other
currencies and our standard of living
goes way down i mean uh we're going to
have to consume a lot less and produce a
lot more we're going to have to borrow a
lot less and save a lot more and you
know this is the antithesis of what
we've been doing and it's going to
happen at a time where capitalism has
never had a worse reputation
and socialism has never had a better
reputation so it's very dangerous
economically and politically for the
united states at this particular point
in its in its uh future
um but
to understand the way the world is going
to look the way relative assets are
going to be valued in the market if you
want to you know be on the receiving end
of this you know this transfer you need
to have the the right portfolio you need
to be investing in the emerging markets
that are going to ultimately receive a
lot of the purchasing power that
americans lose you have to have the
right currencies uh the right asset mix
i mean fortunately you know as everybody
has been piling into all these hyped up
momentum stocks that have been driven by
inflation
there are some good buys around the
world and traditional businesses
companies that actually make stuff that
have real plant equipment that have real
resources that pay good dividends right
now so there are a lot of investments
around the world and that's what we're
trying to tap into
for our clients at your pacific asset
management uh trying to build these
portfolios that will do well in
stagflation with a weak u.s dollar a
weak u.s economy
a less productive u.s economy and more
growth exp you know happening outside
the united states as an american i you
know i'm not happy about that i don't
like the fact that this is going to
happen
but you know i'm not investing based on
what i would like to happen it's based
on what i expect to happen
and uh and you know if i can do
something in the future to help
influence the the path that we take and
i'm trying my best to get us to reject
government and reject you know fiat
money and and embrace capitalism and the
free markets and the constitution i mean
i know that even if we make the right
choices it's going to be difficult first
just like if somebody who's a drug
addict and they make the right choice to
go straight first they're going to go
through withdrawal they might have to go
to rehab and it's not going to be
pleasant so we're going to have to go
through that type of you know monetary
withdrawal
in order to you know come clean and have
a healthy vibrant economy again
hopefully we do uh of course that may
never happen
uh in which case my strategy my
investment strategy is even more
important than if we do the right thing
eventually uh uh if we don't you know
you know getting out of the dollar and
getting into other assets is much more
important again you just you know i
think it's a mistake to get into crypto
uh and think that that's what's going to
protect you
i mean if people want to put a small
amount in crypto just in case i'm wrong
you know i mean you know if it's a small
amount i mean it can't do that much harm
right i mean you know but but the
problem is most people that into it
don't buy a small amount once they get a
small amount they get so greedy they get
a big amount yeah so uh it's it's very
very and you know i don't even want a
small amount because i'm so convinced
that it's gonna go to zero that i'd
rather take that small amount and gamble
on something else
um okay but anyway so my website is uh
for the asset management company you can
see that above my shoulder it's euro
pacific funds epactfunds.com
my gold company is shiftgoal.com if
anybody wants to buy physical
gold and silver as a store of value as
an inflation hedge that's what you
should do you know don't buy you know we
don't deal in numismatics or think you
know rare coins i think that uh that's a
whole different animal i think a lot of
people that really want to buy bullion
end up getting talked into buying
numismatics because the salesman make a
lot more money uh selling those products
so we don't sell those products so you
know we're looking out for for the
customer and and if you know look if
you're looking to buy gold that's what
uh we're selling we're not you know
selling collectibles we're selling an
actual metal uh that has value and
therefore will be a hedge against
inflation
cool
thank you peter very much for coming on
oh my pleasure
hey guys i wanted to talk to you about
nordvpn
i use vpns when i'm traveling which i'm
doing a lot
did you know they don't have disney plus
in serbia do you know what kind of
problem that is
well they do with nordvpn
hopefully that doesn't cause a problem
with me and serbians in the future
i can't believe there are areas of the
world that would ban disney anyway
this isn't supposed to be about disney
or getting access to disney it's about
nordvpn
not only are they sponsoring me which is
fantastic but they allow me to get into
netflix wherever i am if i'm somewhere
sketchy i can also protect myself from
getting my information stolen by using
nordvpn in said sketchy areas
or if you're doing something sketchy on
the
internet a vpn is probably what you're
looking for i also really like nordvpn
because it has the fastest vpn in the
world it doesn't slow down my internet
when streaming in different countries
like other vpns i've used nor vpn
something i would recommend vpns can
come in handy in restaurants airports
and other countries that block certain
websites
i have a fantastic code for 73 off
annually which is pretty huge weird
number pretty huge 73 off at nordvpn.com
tmpp like the michaela peterson podcast
code tmpp for 73 off that's nordvpn.com
tmpp for 73 off annually enjoy the rest
of the episode
[Music]
robert breedlove welcome to my podcast
michaela thank you i'm glad to be here
this should be good but before we get
started can you give a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
sure uh
i my background is in accounting and
finance
i'm a former hedge fund manager
in the crypto asset space and then
largely influenced by your father's work
and the work of some others i've decided
to pivot full-time into education
and a lot of my educational efforts are
focused on history of money economics
philosophy
uh all connected to bitcoin
so a lot of people in the bitcoin
universe call this the bitcoin rabbit
hole
where you start to ask these fundamental
questions like what is money what is
government what is value
and it just uh
unearths these layers of understanding
the world that you didn't previously
have
so
that is the name of the show actually
the what is money show that i recently
just started and i'm just talking to the
smartest people in the world about these
topics
and uh typically in a long form setting
that's very cool smartest people in the
world to talk about what is money and
other topics that sounds fantastic
okay so i guess we should start off
first with probably what is bitcoin
yeah it's a great question um
and i guess we could say that bitcoin is
the most superior monetary technology
that has ever existed
um which naturally segues into the
question
what is money
and there's there's a lot of answers to
that question
um one of the most basic
i like to use is that money is simply a
tool for expressing value across space
and time
um the word tool
is a bit loaded because you we typically
think of a tool as something physical
but money is more of a social construct
and um
people naturally select a monetary
technology that exhibits five properties
historically
and those are divisibility durability
recognizability portability and scarcity
and to just kind of gloss over some
history historically before bitcoin the
best thing we had for money were metals
monetary metals actually
gold specifically became dominant
because it it best exhibited those
properties and of the monetary metals it
was the most scarce
um but with bitcoin we have a tool
that has perfected all of the properties
or services we seek and money everything
that money needs to do
bitcoin has essentially perfected the
deliverance of those properties
so because it's just information it's
infinitely divisible
um
you know you can take each bitcoin and
break it down into 100 million sub units
called satoshi's
that that limit can be increased if
bitcoin was ever not divisible enough we
could increase that limit
because bitcoin's stored as distributed
information all over the world it's
effectively infinitely durable
something kind of like the bible
actually or like the individual bible is
clearly not indestructible but the bible
itself is a book as a concept
is pretty much infinitely
durable because it's everywhere it's
everywhere nowhere
uh bitcoin's infinitely portable because
it's just information you can move it at
the speed of light
and then
uh bitcoin is infinitely recognizable
meaning that you can audit the total
supply you can verify every transaction
you can effectively be your own central
bank by running software
and then finally and very importantly
for money
bitcoin is
as i've argued in some of my writing
the discovery of absolute scarcity
so everything in the world has always
been relatively scarce only like the
more time we allocate towards producing
anything we can produce more of it
of all of the goods and commodities in
the world gold was the most relatively
scarce commodity that's what gave it
this monetary property
that caused it to have market value as
money
but with bitcoin we have perfected that
property of scarcity we have something
that is digital and
has a perfectly fixed supply
and it's really hard to overstate how
big of a deal this is because we've
never had anything that we know with
absolute certainty
uh the supply is fixed at that amount
and this in the case of bitcoin is 21
million
so
that's a nutshell answer the bitcoin is
the best
money we've ever had i think i guess the
big thing to understand that a lot of
people don't is that money is a
technology
we typically think money today we think
it's a
a product issued by government but
that's not the case that's not the truth
actually is money emerges on the
marketplace as a technology
people favoring those properties
of money
um
and then i guess we could get into a bit
of how we went from gold to paper money
if you like
actually that would be interesting but
before i have one question before we get
into that but gold to paper money sounds
good um
what about the fact that you can't use
bitcoin physically for something so for
gold you could turn it into jewelry
or use it in computers or you could use
it but for bitcoin you can't use it like
that do you see that as a problem
yeah so everything that trades in the
marketplace
it's value has two
basically functions so one is
utility value which is what you're
describing you can use it for jewelry
you can use gold in dentistry you can
use it in computers this is the utility
value of gold
and then there's another component of
demand for gold that it is its
marketability or its monetary use case
so
when we look at gold's market cap today
say it's around 10 trillion dollars
approximately one or two trillion of
that
market cap which is the total value of
gold worldwide
is the demand configuration for its use
it's you use as a utility right in
dentistry and computer and all these
things the other eight trillion dollars
of gold's market cap
is demand for gold as money to hold it
as a store of value
so
this is actually another definition of
money is like of every and everything
exhibits a little bit of monetary
premium
um
like anything because you would hold it
in anticipation of trading it in the
future
so gold is just a thing that's held
mostly for its marketability aspect of
value
so you could say the def another
definition of money would be that
commodity which exhibits the greatest
marketability or monetary premium yes
relative to its utility value
so gold would say again eight to two
like a four to one right
bitcoin
has perfected this again by perfecting
the properties of money bitcoin's pure
monetary premium
there's no industrial use to it at all
so you could argue that this is a defect
but bitcoiners would actually take the
position that this is an expression
of bitcoin as a pure money it's like the
first time we've discovered a pure money
and this technology is only good as
money it does nothing else
whereas gold was just kind of this
analog version of bitcoin we were just
doing our best with what we had
that's interesting so that's why it's
referred to as gold 2.0 yeah digital
gold which is a great analogy but you
have to really understand gold and not
many of us do
yes this is true okay you're talking
about gold into paper money is that a
bitcoin tattoo i see it my only tattoo
is a bitcoin tattoo
um yeah
skin in the game is what it means to me
okay okay that makes sense okay you got
something for that that's good yeah okay
um
how did that happen paper sorry gold
into paper money how did that happen
sure so
historically
you know
people are trading with one another in
the global economy everyone's operating
in their own best interest over time
this is what causes the market to
generate prices right as people trade
against one another a price emerges for
good it's constantly changing
it's also what generates innovation
so as an entrepreneur can figure out a
better way of doing something he he or
she has an incentive to sell that into
the marketplace
and that's how we all become more
productive
and and advance
so
throughout this long history of people
trading against one another gold was
selected as money because it best
exhibited those properties
but the shortcoming of gold and monetary
metals more generally
was in the portability property of money
so gold was really good for holding
value over time and that it exhibited
reliable scarcity
in that no matter how hard anyone tried
to produce gold
it was a commodity whose supply we could
increase the most slowly
so if i'm going to park my wealth in
something
as an entrepreneur
i want to put it somewhere that's
maximally resistant to the willpower of
other people
otherwise people are just gonna if you
just put it in
copper for instance if you monetize
copper people go out and produce a lot
more copper a lot more quickly and they
could dilute the value you had stored in
it
so the this this market process is like
a game theoretic discovery process where
you're looking for the most scarce thing
so that's gold was selected for that
it's great tool for storing value over
time
but because it lacked portability
it struggled in its ability to express
value across space
right gold's heavy it's physical it's
expensive to secure it's expensive to
move you need armed guards you need
ships you need safes you need banks all
of these things
so
the market developed this warehousing
function where you could just put your
gold on deposit with a warehouse
custodian
the custodian would issue paper
redeemable for that gold
you could then entrepreneurs were then
free to go into the marketplace and
transact in these paper tokens
that are redeemable for gold
and they you know they basically
monetized that became as good as gold
because they were redeemable for gold so
all of a sudden you had
the property
of scarcity
uh attached to this paper certificate
because it was redeemable for gold but
you also had the portability of paper
right paper is very light and easy to
move around and it became even better
when we abstracted the paper into
electronic form
so that was the that was the purpose of
banking and the purpose of currency is
really to increase
the transactability
of gold to reduce the transaction cost
to increase the velocity of money as a
term used a lot in economics
the problem of course comes that you now
have to trust the custodian
whatever they say whatever gold they say
they have on deposit they have to be
telling the truth otherwise
it's a fraud
and
those warehouse custodians became banks
banks became central banks
and
as i've argued in a lot of my writing
central banking is the greatest fraud in
human history and that we now that
dollar is no longer redeemable for gold
at all
um it's just a confidence game that's
imposed by bureaucrats on market actors
but
it's been done in a way
that you know slowly enough and uh
there's been enough
propaganda i guess built up around it
that we don't need gold we don't need
monetary scarcity
the government should just be able to
control the money supply at will to
to control
the economy frankly that people have
just forgotten all of this history
and
i think it's been pretty disastrous you
know we came off of gold in 1971 so it
was 50 years ago
and as we see today the world is in
in disarray in a lot of dimensions you
know culturally economically
and i think government has kind of run
amok as well
kind of run amok
isn't isn't it isn't it strange then
that the digital currency that
the big one bitcoin wasn't backed on
something like gold to begin with or do
you think that that's an actually an
upside like you would have thought that
the way things have gone it would have
been created backed by something like
gold
well here's the thing about
when we say
backed by gold we have to look one layer
deeper
gold itself is backed by energy or proof
of work
right it's
again we're looking for a money that we
cannot counterfeit
so gold because it's so hard to produce
the most difficult commodity to get
above ground
it
it is secured by proof of work like if
you want to go out and um
harvest the monetary premium that's
stored within gold you have to expend
energy time resources go and dig it out
of the ground
so
in my view gold is just the analog
version of proof of work
which is the consensus and security
model for bitcoin bitcoin is the same
thing
only it's a more direct pathway to
monetizing
energy
so instead of having to spend energy to
go and find gold mine and get it above
ground and sell into the market you can
take bitcoin mining directly to energy
any energy
resource in the world
and you just put this mining rig on top
of it this could be
say a stranded energy a stranded gas
well that's way off grid that's not
economic to sell at all you can now put
bitcoin mining directly onto that
resource
and monetize this this energy that would
have otherwise gone unused
so
when we think i think it's very easy to
think like oh shouldn't we have backed
bitcoin by gold
but satoshi actually went a layer deeper
it's like well what's back in gold
energy is what backs gold so he just um
directly mapped bitcoin onto energy
although you could argue that the actual
physical gold and what you're able to
make it into
also backs gold yeah
yeah you're back to that original uh
debate between utility and marketability
so it's like do you want
a money that does other things or do you
want a money that's a pure money
and if we just look at the the judgments
of market actors historically they've
always favored the purest money
so the bet on bitcoin is that we would
that market dynamic would continue to
play itself out towards the purest money
and that is bitcoin
okay
next question then
part of the upside of bitcoin and other
not all other no well bitcoin let's
stick with bitcoin uh is this
decentralized
but do you not think that at some point
the government's gonna get its paws on
bitcoin
well this is the beautiful thing about
bitcoin is that
it's a monetary technology that's
wrapped in military-grade encryption
optimized to survive any attack or any
threat
and the largest and most obvious
threat here is the nation-state attack
and
really bitcoin has made all of the
design trade-offs to optimize for
survivability so it really
is just designed to turn out a new block
every 10 minutes or on average every 10
minutes and maintain a supply cap of 21
million
it has foregone all of the other bells
and whistles that you'll see
um
other crypto projects experimenting with
you know ethereum
has a lot of these extra features
but bitcoin is is shunning all of this
extra feature set to make sure that it
is optimized for survivability because
if bitcoin succeeds
meaningfully
in the way that many bitcoiners think
that it will it is a threat to the
monopolization of money
which has been the greatest source of
wealth for governments historically
right i mean imagine if you're running a
business and you you owned a money
printing machine
every time you ran into any problem at
all every time you made a bad decision
or there was some unforeseen
circumstance you could just press print
and you know paper over the loss or
paper over the bad decision
it's almost intuitive
how much you would abuse that machine
and that is exactly what governments
have been doing
really throughout all of history but
especially in the past 50 years that
we've systemized
the global financial system and removed
it from gold so that
another way to think of gold is that it
was a
it held governments accountable
so if a government was irresponsible
with their monetary policy historically
which is to say they printed way more
money
than they had in gold reserves gold
would leave their country
so they would actually hurt themselves
economically by being irresponsible but
by breaking the peg to gold
they're able to completely run amok
there's no accountability whatsoever
no one can call the bluff
how did that happen like who agreed that
it wouldn't be linked to gold anymore
so
following world war ii
the us won world war ii
we held the bretton woods conference
and we dictated to the world that the
dollar would be pegged to gold
and that all international currencies
would be pegged to the dollar so we had
this pseudo
gold standard
but
this gave the united states the
advantageous position of being able to
print as many dollars as they want
and we could basically send these
printed dollars to other countries they
would send us goods and services this is
called
been infamously called the exorbitant
privilege to be the global reserve
currency because you can just
basically confiscate goods and services
from other producers so long as they
don't redeem your dollars for gold
but the united states offered we had the
gold window open for countries to redeem
and so countries started calling our
bluff over time
they would actually submit dollars and
demand uh receipt and gold payment in
gold
and in 1971 when germany demanded
payment in gold because they saw that
the united states was printing 20
dollars
nixon
president nixon at the time
did the the infamous nixon shock where
he took us off the gold standard it was
said to be a temporary measure
and of course like every government
temporary measure it was permanent
and uh things have gotten really bad
since from an economic standpoint
wow i had no idea about that thank you
i took american history and they didn't
teach me that
it's funny yeah funny how they rewrite
the history books to leave out the
important stuff
okay
so then what about the volatility that
we're seeing in bitcoin right now
like is it safer if you're trying to
maintain your wealth is it safer to put
your money in something like gold that
seems to just stay stable we don't know
what the future is going to bring
like what about all these older people
that are putting money into bitcoin and
it's going up and down a bit
but did you still think that's the
safest route because the volatility can
be scary
yeah so
volatility i guess the first thing to
understand is
when you're thinking
well here's the the very first thing to
understand is volatility and market
capitalization which is the size of the
asset are inversely proportionate
so the smaller an asset is the more
volatile it will be by necessity you
could look at something like
amazon in the late 90s you know it was
up and down i think it was down
90 percent in 2001 and then it's grown
40 000
so as an asset becomes larger it becomes
more stable
we've seen this pattern play out with
bitcoin as well
as its market cap has increased its
volatility has declined
bitcoin is around 1 trillion asset today
gold again is around 10 trillion
so gold's volatility
is
less than bitcoins because it's
larger than bitcoin by a factor of 10.
so
that's really important to understand is
that as it grows it becomes more stable
kind of intuitive in a lot of ways if
you think about
uh something on the surface of a pond
you know and the ripples come
if it's smaller the ripples are going to
affect it a lot more but if it's larger
it won't be
as effective as much is maybe a useful
visualization
the other thing to understand is that
when we say volatility we're talking
about
its price expressed in dollars typically
so
and this is a really this is a deep
thing about money is it we it's part of
our mental machinery like we're thinking
in dollars all the time right you're
negotiating or planning or
um whatever you're doing in your life
economically you're thinking in dollars
so there's this
psycho-technological aspect to money too
although it's a technology out in the
real world it's also something like
literacy or numeracy it's embedded in
your your your thinking as well
and dollars are being rapidly
depreciated
i mean we
here's a stat that will really blow your
mind
in the past 18 months
40 percent
i'm worried about this already okay
okay go
in the past 18 months
4 out of 10 or 40
of every dollar in existence
was produced
so the federal reserve has been around
since 1913 so for
108 years
of producing dollars
40 of those dollars were produced in the
past 18 months
what
yeah
so the dollar is being rapidly
depreciated through excess production
again because it's not tethered to gold
there's no accountability to governments
whatsoever you can just print money
and dole it out at your whim
don't they know that that goes badly
aren't there laws in place so that they
can't do that
the federal reserve is an unregulated
private institution
what it's not federal and it has no
reserves
and
they it's it's an institution that never
loses it can print money right it just
just prints money so
um
to answer the question don't they know
that it ends badly this
relationship of humanity to money this
is the one lesson we keep learning
painfully like we every three
generations we seem to forget it
that oh you know
we can't print money to solve our
problems but every few generations we're
like we convince ourselves that no we
figured it out it's different this time
we control the economy with these
different lovers those guys three
generations ago didn't know what they
were doing it's all gonna be okay
well right now we're living through
another one of those situations where
there are people with enough
i guess hubris or self-deception even to
believe
that they can print money at infinitum
and somehow control its its deleterious
economic consequences
okay
what do you think is going to happen
with bitcoin
if you had to take a guess
well there's an old
popular saying says don't tell me what
you think just show me what's in your
portfolio
i i hold 100 of my savings in bitcoin so
100 of my liquid savings i hold in
bitcoin
uh
i do
based on my
study of money
government
economics historically
free market actors have always favored
the
monetary technology that best satisfied
these properties
most of human history actually there's
another lens to take on it that we've
been fighting over the gold for all of
human history even the world war ii
situation i just described to you
the reason the u.s you know won is
because a lot of gold
flowed out of europe and into north
america
to as a safe haven a geographic safe
haven from nazi plundering because when
when germany would invade a country
their first stop would be their central
bank to raid their gold
so clearly war is very expensive
countries are fighting over and funding
warfare with money gold right
so
i think that bitcoin
is the digital disrupter to gold and
this is something that is so significant
because
humans have been playing this game of
gold since the beginning of time we've
been fighting over it we've been
coveting it
um and
but the problem is that governments have
gained you know through this mechanism
i've described this ability to
corner the market on gold or corrupt it
or sever the monetary system from gold
because central banks still buy gold by
the way they're still the largest net
purchasers of gold
so they're forcing people to use this
paper currency that's not redeemable for
gold but they themselves are still
acquiring gold
so the game of gold is still being
played even though the you know we don't
think in gold or we're detached from it
at the geopolitical
scale the game of gold goes on
um
you know china is the largest producer
of gold and the largest buyer of gold
clearly they're the biggest threat to
the u.s
hegemony so
this game goes on
my belief is that
bitcoin
is almost like an inflection point into
the digital age that we're we're going
into a time
as transformative
as the transition from agricultural to
the industrial age the industrial age
the digital age is similar
and i think that bitcoin is going to
disrupt
gold and every other monetary network
built on top of it which includes
dollars euros yen everything worldwide
and i think this becomes the ultimate
honest money
hard money store value in the world it's
the the premier asset
worldwide
and i view bitcoin really is disruptive
to those three things gold
centralized government which is the
institution that hoards gold
and importantly global warfare
world war one and world war ii would not
have been possible without fiat currency
the scale and duration of warfare is
funded through fiat currency inflation
before
when governments were on a gold standard
say historically they had to wage war
within the confines of their own balance
sheet they had a war chest
right they have enough money to go to
war and what would typically happen is
one of the combatants would go broke or
go close to broke and they would strike
a deal so war tend to be tended to be
very brief
um very intermittent and quickly kind of
resolved whereas
as you know ron paul said this it's no
coincidence that the century of total
war
and the century of central banking were
the same century
inflation
fiat currency inflation
has increased the scale and duration of
warfare that led to all of the
atrocities
in the 20th century it's been the
stealth funding mechanism for every
dictator every internment camp and every
world war in history so i think bitcoin
is a peaceful protest
frankly against this economic tyranny
that we've we've come to see in
government
okay that definitely went in a direction
that i wasn't expecting
i don't think i've heard any of that
before that's very interesting
okay
i need to look at my notes what other
questions do i have here
what happens potentially
so the only way bitcoin is going to
work or is if people can use it easily
right to buy things with it easily so is
it still going to be the mode of
currency people use to buy things or is
that going to be on something like
ethereum because i've been like
tinkering around with both and i know
that
ethereum seems easier to
buy things with but that could just be
because i'm doing things wrong i have no
idea
uh so
again looking uh historically
gold
followed this path of monetization and
that it was initially it was just a
collectible at first people just liked
gold because it was shiny right you'd
would wear it you'd ornament yourself
with it etc
that created
some demand for gold as a collectible
and then uh based on its scarcity it
then became a store of value so people
actually started storing wealth there
long term right intergenerationally even
uh whether in jewelry or bars or
whatever
eventually once gold had stored enough
economic value people started to use it
as a medium of exchange right there's an
incentive
if you have something that has a ton of
economic value stored in it
as that value grows your incentive to
spend it grows right its purchasing
power is increasing you can go out and
buy more things so of course
um
there's a natural path for its
incentives to turn it from a store value
into medium exchange finally when people
are using it widely enough as a medium
of exchange that's when it starts to
enmesh itself in our mental architecture
so we actually start to denominate
prices
in gold right again we think in dollars
today but the only reason we think in
dollars is because they used to be
redeemable for gold
so there's almost like this bait and
switch that the central bank pulled on
us so we all were thinking in dollars
because it was a free market money and
then it's like oh not anymore
it's just this paper currency but
because people are detached from this
process and the dollar itself didn't
change
uh
you know they're able to get away with
it so
that's the path
you would expect bitcoin to follow it
doesn't actually need to be
to succeed it doesn't need to be used
widely as a medium of exchange like it
can
it can go on being a store value for a
really long time
again if store value the main property
you want to store value is scarcity i
want to hold my wealth in something i
know that no one else can print or
produce
and that bitcoin's perfected that right
we know with absolute certainty
if you hold a thousand bitcoin you've
got 1 000 out of a possible 21 million
forever
so it's it's perfected that
you can then take bitcoin
and you can borrow against it i mean you
know you can swap it for dollars you can
swap it into a medium of exchange as
needed so it doesn't
need the medium of exchange function to
succeed
that said i would i would argue
to look into the lightning network and
to look into other higher level higher
order protocol developments so there's
layers being built on top of bitcoin
yeah that makes certain trade-offs to
make it much more
useful much more transactable
in the similar to how we tran we
abstracted gold into a paper currency to
make it more transactable
there's a lot of cost
and slowness and energy expenditure at
the bitcoin base layer to keep it secure
that's a trade-off that it's making
but it will
it makes different trade-offs at higher
layers to make it more transactable so i
think the path
of bitcoin's evolution is in layers so
we have bitcoin base layer you'll see it
become very trans it's already very
transactible on the lightning network
today
um
there's a great company in the space
called strike that's that's globalizing
this you know they recently implemented
uh in el salvador so
i think that's the pathway that bitcoin
will go
does it have
so i know part of the problem with
ethereum is the gas fees does it have
cheaper gas fees
is it even called gas fees on the
lightning network these are all words
yeah it's not called gas fees the
transaction fees are
like near zero on the lightning network
very small very minuscule
um
and it gives you
you know again how we talked about the
warehouse function where we abstracted
gold into paper and that worked as long
as you could redeem the paper for gold
lightning network is sort of similar but
you always have the option to redeem no
one can suspend your opposite option to
redeem it for bitcoin
so it's this layer that
is almost like a hyper liquid layer that
lets you move bitcoin very fast very
cheap
you can basically settle anywhere in the
world with finality instantly
and then you know when you're done you
just
redeem for bitcoin so you're you're
you're funding a channel a lightning
channel to transact and then you're
redeeming that channel back into bitcoin
to settle
so what happens if a bunch of these
people who hold a bunch of bitcoin end
up switching it back into fiat wanting
to buy things
this is this is the market process of
bitcoin so if people that hold bitcoin
want fiat they can sell they could trade
bitcoin for fiat people do this every
day bitcoin's got
i think it's daily volumes around eight
to ten billion dollars a day i mean it's
very liquid
it's global it's a trillion dollar asset
uh and again the other option is people
can borrow against it the
the lending market in bitcoin is is
becoming quite mature where
because bitcoin is this 24x7 asset it's
a bearer asset so when i send it to you
it's as if i sent you a gold coin
there's no
it's unencumbered just by possessing it
that means you own it essentially you
don't need to do a title search or
anything like that on bitcoin so it's
kind of the the ultimate or pristine
collateral in a way that you can just
send this digital bearer asset
to a lender and they'll you know say you
send them a hundred thousand dollars in
bitcoin they'll loan you 50 000 or 30
000 depending on your loan to value
ratio
and that's another way to get liquidity
and a lot of people opt for that so you
don't
you can maintain your bitcoin holdings
without having to sell it
but still get liquidity and fiat for
spending
that's interesting i didn't know you
could do that what do you have to pay
for that
i mean there's different companies that
have different rates um
you know there's a big company in the us
called nida that does a lot of this for
institutions high net worth individuals
i you know
you'd have to check with them on their
rates i would just ballpark it around
eight to 12 percent a year
hmm
okay wow
i have no idea what to think
i have no idea what to think what do you
think is going to happen with inflation
given how rapidly you said 40 of
everything printed was printed in the
last 18 months
every dollar in existence four out of
ten every dollar in existence is that
just an america is that that's in
existence that's in existence yeah so
what who's doing this is that just
americans
well this is the federal reserve this is
quantitative easing every time you hear
quantitative easing
the debt ceiling printing money
all of these
euphemisms just mean they're expanding
the money supply
and when they're expanding the money
supply you can translate this in your
mind to
they're stealing property from people or
they're stealing time from people
and i'm not this isn't even an opinion
frankly you can look at it mechanically
and there's i don't think there's any
other way to evaluate it
so a couple ways to think about this one
would
be again money is just pure
marketability right it doesn't have any
value except what it can be traded for
so if there's one group of people that
can print money that everyone else is
forced to use
they're able to confiscate
property and value from those people
that are being forced to use it
um and that's what inflation is right
essentially so it's been wrapped in all
these different
uh academic jargons like it's useful and
necessary for a healthy economy but it's
just it's just not true
um another way
why did that come around sorry didn't
drop but what like how did people
convince other people that inflation was
necessary and a good thing
well when you own the money printer you
tend to gain a disproportionate
you gain disproportionate leverage in
academia
uh you could look at the entire
emergence of keynesian economics versus
austrian economics and this is the big
divide between central banking and and
bitcoiners
austrian economics was the
cumulative knowledge of humanity in the
sphere of economics throughout all of
history basically
and then when uh central banking emerged
in earnest this alternative branch of
economics called keynesian economics
uh on you know largely under a guy named
john maynard keynes
emerged as an alternative view of
economic reality that really just
justified
monopolizing money frankly and it if you
look at and this is all they teach in
college by the way again
i have a master's degree in accounting
finance they didn't teach me one letter
of austrian economics
zero zilch but i learned plenty of
keynesian economics and in keynesian
economics you're taught that essentially
the government is god
they're like literally it's the top of
the page in the textbook it issues money
into circulation and takes money out of
circulation there's no consideration of
the government as a human organization
like they don't suffer any trade-offs
they have perfect knowledge there's no
politics you know it's just this perfect
institution representation of the
government yeah yes yes and as we all
know that's completely ludicrous frankly
yeah
um so that's how it emer i mean
i don't want to get
into this argument people are like oh no
that's not true they didn't mean to do
that people always want to argue with me
about the intentions you know people
think like central bankers are really
trying to do a good job
and i'm agnostic actually to their
intentions because it's like it doesn't
matter if you're trying to do a good job
or not
the mechanical design of the central
bank
is
they're
running a pyramid scheme fiat currency
is a pyramid scheme so it's those with
access to the newly printed money first
get rich
at the expense of those who get it
latest and last
so
if you just look at the operating
mechanics of fiat currency
it's a really bad deal
for everyone unless you have access to
that new liquidity first
so
how did we get here i think just
unchecked human greed you know it's
one of the ways i like to describe the
free market is
it's the collective expression of the
logos actually so whatever we're buying
whenever we're buying and selling we're
effectively voting
so when you buy a car you're telling the
market to make more cars you sell a
house you're telling the market to make
less houses
when you corrupt
the medium through which those those
preferences are expressed the buying and
selling
which is money then you are distorting
the economic democracy of the free
market
and all of a sudden if the fed is
printing money and buying the shares of
this company that's not because the
company was demanded by market actors
it's not like it was doing something
useful and people wanted
that you know more shares in that
company to be bought it's because
bureaucrats decided in a backroom deal
that they're going to print money and go
buy shares of this company whether or
not it's producing any economic benefit
so you move away from energy companies
yeah exactly so you move it's distorting
the collective logos
and this is like a key point where i
think we we today think
that democracy
state democracy is like the ultimate
form of governance
but i would argue that
the free market perfects what state
democracy
approximates
we think one person one vote is there is
the right degree of fairness but that
gets distorted in all these different
ways
the real true
pure democracy is the free market itself
with honest undistorted money
um but you know
thanks to man's greedy ways and very
inventive machinations he found a way to
basically get a perpetual free lunch
by monopolizing money and this is again
what every government throughout history
has done it's always like control the
money to control the people
so
that's where we're at
and you don't think there's any way that
the government's going to be able to
regulate bitcoin like what about if
you're trying to i've seen i can't
remember where i was where you could
potentially buy property with bitcoin
i'm sure that's popping up in areas and
then isn't that going to have to be
taxed in some way in order to
in order for governments to allow
bitcoin to exist and hasn't china tried
to ban it a bunch of times
yeah china's banned bitcoin multiple
times um i guess the key point is this
that
regulation on bitcoin is ultimately
ineffective
you're not going to be able to change
any of the rules of bitcoin by passing a
rule in the jurisdictional world
so
what they can regulate are the end
points so you know if you're trading it
for real estate or anything
to buy shares in a company governments
are very good at regulating centralized
entities institutions physical land
but they're very poor at dealing with
decentralized
institutions or entities which that's
basically what bitcoin is a
decentralized
business
so
i actually look at it the opposite way
that i think
in the same way gold was
a regulator of government historically
and that's
largely why governments had to devise
such
um
an intelligent way to co-opt gold
because gold was holding them
accountable right they couldn't be
irresponsible with money because gold
would leave their country and
uh
this forced them to get very creative
and how they they control the market for
gold
i think bitcoin will provide a similar
function and that it will actually be a
regulator
of government
um so if you're if you're overly
tyrannizing your people or you're overly
inflating or whatever people are just
going to move their wealth into bitcoin
and
leave to the country where they're
treated best
so the other the
the point here again is like
the more dollars you print the more
inflation you create inflation's just a
tax they're just stealing wealth from
you full stop there's nothing else to it
people
market actors are voluntarily going to
figure out okay you're taxing me you're
stealing from me
i want to put my money somewhere that
can't be inflated or taxed as easily
which is bitcoin and then they have this
whole world of options open up to them
which is you have this hyper mobile
globally liquid capital you can go
anywhere in the world
so
i think bitcoin
causes government to shrink over time
dramatically
do you think that's only possible for
people who are
smarter though because like bitcoin is
kind of difficult to figure out if you
have no idea what it is even it's a
complex completely different concept
it's been difficult for me to wrap my
head around it but i think i've wrapped
my head around it and then getting up
and moving to a different country that
requires a type of person a super open
individual then you have to have some
money in order to do that so aren't we
talking about the tiniest percentage of
the population or do you think that's
just going to grow
in the beginning yes and i think that's
what you're seeing today there's a
there's a
small minority of people that tend to be
disagreeable
libertarian minded
independent thinking
curious
there's a
number of other traits i'm sure we could
put there but
that have gone into bitcoin yeah open
that have gone into bitcoin first
but over time i don't think here's the
one constant i guess you could say in
statism is they're not going to stop
printing money
they have to keep printing more money to
actually service prior debts that
they've accumulated so
uh you know
social security medicare all these
things there's tons of unfunded
liabilities
and they have to print money to service
those so the more
dollars they print the more demand they
create for unprintable money
which is bitcoin so i think people get
forced into this over time
and then
you're talking about disrupting the
revenue model for states
you know
direct taxation and inflation are kind
of the two revenue models inflation
effectively goes away in a bitcoin world
and then taxation becomes much more
difficult
to impose because the citizen has a lot
of negotiating leverage
if you want to you know just send me a
bill and tell me what my tax rate is
well maybe i leave your country and
maybe i decide i don't want to
participate
in your regime anymore you know it so it
it it's pulling governments into more of
a free market competition
over citizens actually and so when
governments compete citizens win we'll
get lower prices better services more
innovation all these things the free
market provides that the government has
restricted itself from through the
monopolization of money
where are you located if you don't mind
me asking i'm in hawaii currently
okay so you're still in the u.s then you
haven't
hopped down to like puerto rico or
something i i hopped out for a bit but
i'm back i feel good kind of in the
place i'm in hawaii now i've got one
foot out and one foot in it feels like
that's fair i just moved out of canada
so you bringing up the government taking
all of my money and
yeah i feel that i you you moved to
nashville right
yes i'm from i'm from tennessee
originally so nashville it's an amazing
city
it's wonderful i love it i'm it's full
of allergens but it's better than
being full of
i'll probably just end that sentence
[Laughter]
but i like it it's fun
do i have other questions for you
i don't know what to think about this
whole thing
i think probably just having money in
other things that aren't the us dollar
at the moment
is a good idea how do you feel about
other cryptocurrencies
like ethereum or
or any of the other you know tokens or
coins that are around
yeah i
don't think there's a market proven use
case for anything
in the crypto universe except bitcoin
i'm not saying that there can't be at
some point
my general advice is that bitcoin
is money it is the internet of money or
the digital gold you know there's all
these analogies that partially describe
it
everything else i describe as liquid
venture capital
so yeah okay could be something
but there's probably you know
99 will fail
okay
that makes sense
where can people find you online if
they'd like to find you online learn
more about bitcoin what you do
yes i'm on twitter uh at
breedlove22 which is my last name
brwedlove22
can also find me there's links to
everything there but
the show is called the what is money
show
and we're at
what is money
show podcast dot com i think
or you can find us on youtube
okay i'll link all those below
thank you very much for coming on that
was fun
thanks makayla thanks for having me
[Music]
you